مخطوطات بريئة مألوفة لطفل
ولكن هذا الطفل مر بتجربة
لا يمكن تصورها من بين ما يقرب من 100 مريض تم
إجلاؤهم من غزة إلى مستشفى دي آي، حيث
تحولت حاملة طائرات هليكوبتر فرنسية إلى
سفينة مستشفى مجهزة
بمرافق طبية متخصصة ويقول الأطباء هنا إنهم
أجروا بالفعل 130 عملية جراحية  في ما يزيد قليلاً عن
شهر مع مرضى لا تتجاوز أعمارهم
ثلاث سنوات وإصابات تتراوح بين
الحروق الشديدة إلى
عمليات بتر الأطراف، كنا نذهب إلى الفراش
ليلاً أتذكر أنني غطيت وجهي
ببطاني، يقول ماهر البالغ من العمر 10 سنوات ثم
فجأة وجدت نفسي في المستشفى
لا أعرف ماذا
حدث مثل كثيرين في عمره.
كان حلمي أن أصبح
لاعب كرة قدم. آثار
الغارة الجوية لا تزال مؤلمة في ذاكرة ماه.
تم إجلاء محمد البالغ من العمر عامين أيضًا في
ديسمبر/كانون الأول بعد أن أصيبت ساقه بجروح خطيرة، كما
تقول عمته.  أن
صعوبات التعلم التي يعاني منها محمد تعني أنه غير قادر
على فهم الرعب الذي تركوه بشكل كامل.
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
خلف صور أفراد الأسرة الذين
قُتلوا، يبدو أن أبناء وبنات إخوتهم لا نهاية لهم،
جميع الأطفال الذين شوهدوا في هذا
الفيديو قُتلوا جميعًا، كما تقول عندما كان
ملجأهم الأمم المتحدة  لقد تم قصف المدرسة،
وآمل أن أتمكن من العودة إلى غزة لأكون مع
أي عائلة تركتها، وآمل فقط أن
يكونوا بخير، وهذا كل ما يمكننا أن نأمله
في هذه الحياة، والتمسك بهذا الأمل
يصبح أكثر صعوبة مع مرور كل
يوم، وبينما  يبذل الفريق الطبي هنا قصارى
جهده لشفاء الجروح الجسدية
لمرضاه، ومن الواضح أن
الندوب العاطفية لهذه الحرب تتعمق
عندما يصل المرضى إلى هنا،
كلهم ​​لديهم هذه النظرة في أعينهم
مما يجعلك تشعر أنهم خرجوا
من شيء ما.
يقول الدكتور هوبر إنه أمر صادم بعض الشيء بالنسبة لنا،
فنحن لسنا معتادين على رؤية هذه النظرة
خاصة من
الأطفال داخل غزة، ويبدو الموت شبه
مستحيل الهروب منه، وبالنسبة
لآلاف الجرحى لا يوجد راحة،
فالغالبية العظمى من المستشفيات في
القطاع  لم يعد الأطباء العاملون
مجبرين على العمل في ظل
الضربات الجوية الإسرائيلية المتواصلة مع
الإمدادات الطبية المحدودة، ولم يتم حتى الآن سوى حفنة صغيرة من
جرحى الحرب الذين تم إجلاءهم من
مرافق مثل هذه، إلا أن
عملية الإخلاء
محفوفة بالمخاطر، وبينما جثث
هؤلاء الناجين الممزقة أصبحت الآن ببطء
على  إصلاح البعض حولوا عقولهم
إلى إعادة تشكيل أجزاء من حياتهم في
الوطن، bash CNN في Alish Northern
SI